>> From the Library of
Congress in Washington D.C.
>> I am so delighted to
introduce Gail Godwin today,
because she is the author of one
of my favorite novels, Evensong,
which I've been recommending
to people
since it was published 10 years ago.
[ Applause ]
>> Gail is impossible to pigeonhole.
Her career has been so successful
across so many different forms;
novels, short stories,
nonfiction, memoir, and even Oprah.
And without discounting the role
of imagination, it's safe to say
that Ms. Godwin is an artist who
uses her own life beautifully
as an inspiration for her work.
She was raised in North Carolina,
where her mother was a college
teacher and a journalist
and a writer of romance stories.
She went to a catholic school,
which many of us now
fell we know something
about from her new
novel, Unfinished Desires.
After earning a journalism
degree at Chapel Hill,
she worked as a reporter
from Miami Herald,
an experience that inspired her
new novel, Queen of the Underworld.
And as she worked for the US travel
service of the embassy of London,
which you can get a flavor off
from her novella, Mr. Bedforth.
In 1967, she went to the Iowa
Writers' Workshop, and in 1970,
she published her first
novel, The Perfectionist.
Three times, she has been a finalist
for the National Book Award.
She's received a Guggenheim
Fellowship
and two National Endowment Grants.
What we look forward in
Gail Godwin's writing,
and what we always find there, is
deep inside into the human heart
and the willingness that's
all too rare nowadays
to consider the spiritual
issues that motivate, inspire,
and challenge thoughtful people.
Please help me in welcoming her.
[ Applause ]
[ Pause ]
>> Thank you, Ron Charles.
I've been an admirer of Ron
Charles for quite some time.
He used to be the book editor of
the Christian Science Monitor.
And then, now, he is the book editor
of Book World, Washington Post.
And he has taking on this great
new risk, I think, and you--
if you haven't seen them yet, he
has done three that I know of.
Is that right, Ron?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Five. He has done five
videos, and you can get
through Washington Post, either
Book World or [inaudible],
in which he reviews
books, and there is a lot
of very professional film work.
So I recommend that.
That's one way to keep up
with our interesting times.
I was very lucky to be invited
to the first Book Festival,
and that was nine years ago.
It was on a Saturday, like this,
and it was September 8, 2001.
And things were so much--
they were different.
It's like looking at everything
back then in the sepia tones.
They had us read the night before.
Some of us read.
And then we met president and
Mrs. Bush in the green room,
and I'm being an author who likes
to stay at home as much as she can.
I was noticing details so I
could take them back home.
And I noticed that many of the
men were wearing-- oh, Lord.
Can you click those up for me-- they
wearing a black ties, their tuxedos,
but they were wearing
black cowboy boots.
[ Laughter ]
>> And when I spoke with Laura Bush,
who actually just finished her
performance next door as a writer,
she said she was always
nervous about this festival.
She had-- she started a very
successful one in Texas,
when George W. Bush was the
governor, and she wanted to try
to bring it to Washington.
And she said that I have
to do is worry a lot
to make sure it goes well.
And she must have worried a
lot because it all went well,
until the following Tuesday.
But meanwhile, we're
still on Saturday.
So the next thing then, we went
over to the Library of Congress,
and the president was there, vice
president, all the cabinet sat
at the table with the Attorney
General, John Ashcroft,
and I had just given a reading from
Avan Song, is that scene where the--
where Margaret is-- she is a priest
and she's a [inaudible] in a school
for rich delinquents,
really, is what it is.
And she tells them if
they want someone to come
and say night prayers
with them, to put--
to make a sign and put it
on the door that says NP.
And that's how she knows.
And then she's surprised at
how many people really put work
into their signs.
They're works of art.
So at the table for eight,
Mr. Ashcroft said to me,
"I wish somebody would
make me a night prayer sign
that I could hang on my door."
This is still September 8.
And so, when I got
home and recovered
from all this extraversion,
I spent several days--
[ Laughter ]
>> -- making him a
beautiful night prayer card.
And to do this, you
want to have a design
that doesn't leave any white space.
So everything is filled in.
And then while you're doing
it, you think of that person.
And then I wrote him a
letter and I mailed it off,
and I got a letter back
several weeks after 09/11,
and it said thank you so
much for thinking of me
and so on and wishing me well.
Not a word about the prayer
card, and I have a feeling--
you know, I did it in colored ink
so they may have looked suspicious.
[ Laughing ]
>> I have a feeling he never got it.
Anyway, that was 2001.
And then there is quite a different
feeling at this one for me.
For instance, at the Washington
Post breakfast this morning,
but we no longer-- we had it at the
White House then, nine years ago,
and I remember somebody said,
"If you want the lady's room,
you go down-- we were
on the east room--
go down that long hall and turn
left, and go down the stairs,
and there is a nice ladies room.
And I went wandering off all
by myself, and sure enough,
there was this beautiful
room with all the portraits
of all the first ladies,
Eleanor just as she'd come in.
That's over.
This morning, several people spoke--
several writers spoke about
the importance of being alone.
Now, isn't that interesting?
A big book festival, authors--
because that's when you read,
and that's when you write.
I was cheered out by that.
[ Laughter ]
>> I did give a long time to--
what I might say to you today,
what you'd like to hear.
I didn't write a speech.
But lately, in the
last five or six years,
I have developed this marvelous
ability to just lie down flat
in my bed, and think
and think in paragraphs.
So I thought of what
I wanted to say.
I first, wanted to introduce myself
to you whether you've
read on me or not.
I am a seasoned writer.
I have been publishing novels--
publishing them for 40 years,
writing them for longer.
I've been supporting myself
by writing novels for
the last 30 years.
And this summer has been very quite.
I had a book tour earlier
in the spring,
and then this summer was quiet, and
I reached page 90 of my 14th novel,
and that usually means that
it's not gonna die on me.
[ Laughter ]
>> Now, I came across this essay.
I've read it before, but I
looked it up online again.
If you haven't read it, you must.
It's-- just put up in
Google, Orwell, Why I write,
and George Orwell wrote this
classic essay about why he wrote,
and here is the paragraph
that just fascinates me.
He says of a writer, his
subject matter will be determined
by the age he lives in.
But before he begins to write,
he will have acquired
an emotional attitude
from which he will
never completely escape.
>> And I started thinking
about that, and it's--
you know, what is my
emotional attitude.
And I have the feeling that it is
something about wanting to escape
from whatever confines I'm
in, and at the same time,
more and more realizing the precious
gifts of the shadows to be found
in that-- in those unless confines.
As Mr. Francis [phonetic]
said, just before me,
that you keep writing your
books to side with you friends
and to fight your enemies.
And an emotional attitude is
certainly choosing your friends
and fighting your enemies.
I think that the human--
the characters in books,
and the human characters
that attract me the
most are the ones who--
they always have a mystery to them,
and they're never completely solved.
There is something unfinished
about them, which brings me
to my latest novel, my 13th
novel, called Unfinished Desires.
I'm gonna talk about that for
a few minutes, but I first have
to tell you that this novel was
first called something else.
It was first called something
else in the contract.
else with the first cover,
and the publisher just kept
saying, "Please, please, please,
please change the tittle because
nobody is going to buy this book.
Everybody who has been to a catholic
girl school is gonna say, no.
I don't want that book.
I don't want anything to do with
nuns who hit you with a ruler."
And at first, I tried to
argue my point [inaudible],
no nun ever hit me with a ruler.
The original title of the book
was-- and I wish still were--
the Red Nun, A Tale
of Unfinished Desires.
And so, we finally compromised
on Unfinished Desires.
They thought that would do well
in all the different
venues where it had to go.
And I'm afraid that some people
might have bought Unfinished Desires
and hoped there was
something else in it.
[ Laughter ]
>> But there is enough of that too.
This novel was born in me during
an online interview with an editor
who was asking me-- he was doing an
anthology on his favorite stories,
and he had picked one ghost
story called Dream Children.
And he was asking me about my
favorite kinds of ghost stories,
and I said my favorite probably in
the world is one called Playmates
by A.M. Burrage, and English writer,
my second favorite is
Chekhov's, The Black Monk.
And I said I like ghost
stories that are psychological,
where you feel the
character is being haunted
from inside and may not know it.
And quite a few people in
my novel, Unfinished Desire,
a.k.a The Red Nun, are haunted.
Now, I went to a school that looked
like the one in Unfinished Desires.
If you wanna look at that school,
I tried to make a drawing of it.
It's on my website,
gailgodwin.com, go on to that
and then click on Gail's art.
And there's a-- and then go--
then click on the Red Nun,
and you will find a
picture of this school.
And I added some gloom and some
clouds, but it's that school.
It was an old hotel in
Asheville, North Carolina.
It was on top of a mountain.
It used to be a sanatorium.
Then part of it burned down,
then it was an orphanage,
and then some nuns came from France
and from England and bought it
and started a school there.
At first, there was a lot of
anti-catholic sentiment and--
but then, it became the school
where everybody wanted
to send their children.
And the bishop of North Carolina,
the Catholic Bishop, complained.
He said, "Here, we have this
school run by catholic nuns,
and it's mostly Protestants
and Jews who go to it."
I'm really glad I went there
because it set up a mood in me.
I can still follow it in my sleep.
I could follow the rooms.
And there is-- there are
several characters in there.
I won't say their autobiographical,
'cause one is the nun.
She is an old nun.
She is 85 years old.
She is blonde.
She is trying to bright
a memoir of the school
that will show her the good light.
And to make all this short
because we gonna have questions,
through writing this book,
I discovered true working
with Mother Ravenel, who is
writing her memoirs in 2001,
which is going back to the
schools beginning to 1908.
She somehow resolves the issue in
her between of rampant ambition,
which I think I must have had,
and a place for a spiritual life.
So the only revenge I can get
on my publishers for this change
of title was, in the paper
back, there is place in the back
where you have an interview
with the author,
and I said I've had
enough interviews
with the author in the other books.
So let's let me have a few
characters interview me.
And one of them is Mother Ravenel,
and I have her just give me hell
for changing the tittle of the book.
[ Laughter ]
>> I'm now open to
questions and conversation.
Thank you very much.
[ Applause ]
[ Pause ]
>> How do you do this?
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> I mean, I've been watching
you, and it's very impressive.
[ Inaudible Remark ]
>> Does someone want to talk?
Oh, okay. They're walking
the mic over.
[ Inaudible Discussion ]
>> They told me to walk to the mic.
>> Well, okay.
Walk [inaudible] mic.
>> Oh, that's good.
>> In Evensong, you have a beautiful
paragraph there about longings
and desire and the origins of it,
and I was fascinated with that.
That's the reason why I
picked up Unfinished Desires.
Are you expanding that particular
concept of longings that are hidden
and can be explained
eventually in one's life?
>> May I take you with me
on the rest of my trip?
>> Sure.
>> Actually, yes.
Did everyone hear her
question, longings and desire?
Are you working on it-- are
you still working on it?
Yes, I am.
And my new novel is-- I made
even more of a pressure cooker
with just a few people
with longings and desires.
Yes, I want to get
really down in there.
>> Thank you.
>> Okay.
>> Yes?
>> Hi. I want-- would
like to know who are some
of your favorite contemporary
writers,
and what are you reading now.
>> I had just finished--
I just hate to say this.
You're not gonna believe it.
But I just reread Anna
Karenina and War and Peace,
and I'm rereading Hilary Mantel's,
Wolf Hall, with great envy.
I read every book-- every
literary novel that comes out--
when it comes out, because that's
when I do in the evenings now.
I read as I watch a couple of shows,
like the Rachel Maddow [phonetic]
show or [inaudible] show,
and Masterpiece Mystery
and Doctor House,
and Boardwalk Empire and Mad Men.
That's about it.
[ Laughter ]
>> Thank you.
>> I think I have read every
literary novel that's come
out this year.
And I've read, of course,
Jonathan Franzen's Freedom.
I was looking at my old
interview that they take
for the first Book Festival,
and someone was asking me,
"What have you been reading?"
and I said I'm reading this new
author called Jonathan Franzen,
Corrections, and I'm
rereading Jane Austen's Emma.
So it's about the same.
And I reread Elizabeth Bowen a
lot, and my new novel, I will say,
is my tribute to Henry James.
I have been fascinated by the
Turn of the Screw for decades.
And now, I'm gonna write my Turn
of the Screw with a bow to him.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> Hi, Gail.
>> Hi.
>> Hi. I attended the school,
as you know, that you wrote
about in Unfinished Desires.
>> What year were you?
Or do you want-- never mind.
>> No, I don't mind.
[ Laughter ]
>> '56. And now, I just--
I've write it twice, actually,
and I just really loved it.
And I was wondering if you
had any response from people
who might recognize
themselves in the novel.
>> Well, not-- no.
But long before I wrote it--
in fact, when I was
writing another book--
when I was writing
a Southern Family,
I wanted to get some information on
that order, that religious order.
And by mistake, my
researcher put me in touch
with the original Mother Ravenel
who did not get her claws into me
because I left town before
I got to her [inaudible].
But then, she reconnected with
me in her old age and my old age,
and she started sending me
tapes telling me how to write
and what words to leave in.
[ Laughter ]
>> I can see it now.
>> So I got an insight into her.
It was very valuable, that you know,
we wanna keep control
over what we have.
She wanted to keep control
over one of her old girls.
So she very much influenced me in
terms of looking and seeing how much
of me was in her, and how she could
get have a spiritual right life
as well.
>> Good. Thank you.
>> Hi.
>> The protagonist in Evensong began
in Father Melancholy's daughter,
are there any other characters
from your older books that you'd
like to revisit and
resurrect in a future work?
>> No, but I wold like to resurrect
Magda and the good husband,
she's dead, even in the book.
And there are certain
kinds of characters
that you don't finish with,
like Unfinished Desires,
there is a character
called Mod [phonetic],
who's troubled right
into her old age.
So she didn't get a start
in writing until she is 70.
And I'm doing another character like
that in my new book as a girl of 10,
and she's alone with
her summer guardian
who is a very peculiar woman.
And that's the Turn
of the Screw slant.
>> Thank you.
>> You're welcome.
>> Hi.
>> Yes.
>> I have more of a comment and
appreciation than a question, and--
>> Oh, thank you.
>> I guess I've been an avid
reader since I was six or seven,
and probably been an
avid reader of your works
since you started writing.
>> Oh, thank you.
>> And have just-- am so--
you're what inspired me to come
down here in the mall today.
And I just--
>> [Inaudible] with you
back to the convent.
[ Laughter ]
>> So I'm just delighted to see
your progress, and follow it.
I have a couple other questions,
but I'll write you an email.
I presume on your website,
there is someway to--
>> If you email me, just be
sure to put Gail K. Godwin,
'cause there is a lot
of Gail Godwin's.
There is a tennis champion, there
is a Brooklyn School teacher,
there is a painter.
So gailkgodwin@yahoo.com.
>> Okay, I will.
Thank you very much.
>> Thank you so much, .
I think that's all.
That's our time.
Been a pleasure.
[ Applause ]
>> This has been a presentation
of the Library of Congress.
Visit us at loc.gov.